now to our exclusive reporting on new
york governor andrew cuomo and his
deadly nursing home scandal we are
hearing
a new side to his decision to force
nursing homes to accept patients
infected with coronavirus for the first
time a nursing home administrator is
speaking on camera
about the governor's controversial order
that covid patients be put in long-term
care facilities
rather than in hospitals aisha hosni
spoke with that administrator
my position from the get-go was
we can't do it michael krauss is the
administrator of silver lake specialized
care center in staten island new york
and for the first time
he and his team are telling us what
really happened behind closed doors when
governor andrew cuomo
issued that controversial march 25th
order
it required all nursing homes to take in
covet patients
released from overwhelmed hospitals he
says he first heard about it on a covet
conference call
with other administrators hospital
leaders and state officials
i said that's ridiculous everyone heard
about the story that happened in
washington state
and you know that was enough for me to
to understand
i can't put these people at risk we
can't be doing this
it's it's just not right to the
residents and you vocalize that
on these phone conversations i did
vocalize it
and then you know once it was shot down
i never spoke again there are more
important people than me
who thought it was a good idea who was
it shot down by
i couldn't tell you some of the it was
on a conference call
i don't know kraus says many other
administrators
rang the alarm and then just four days
into the new order
the nation's largest association
representing long-term and post-acute
care providers
pushed out this stark warning we
strongly object to this policy directive
it reads
this action by a state will put the many
frail and older adults who reside in
nursing homes at risk
the group even offered recommendations
to reduce that risk
we think that the governors in every
state
follow that advice with the exception of
new york
at the time krauss feared his facility
didn't have enough ppe
he says his vendors told him they had to
prioritize hospitals
so he followed his gut and locked down
we would take back our own patients
because that's only fair
but to take on new cases i felt was
unfair
so we shut down the entire operation we
had no admissions for about 10 weeks
maybe longer i don't remember and
i mean that was my way of following the
governor's order
but refusing to take in patients from
hospitals
came with consequences many facilities
were
were threatened by hospitals to take the
covert patients
threatened in what way well i mean again
i never saw the exact
emails but they were threatened that
they um they would be reported
for non-compliance um
i think in in our case we weren't
allowed
we were told please don't send us your
sick patients
there were multiple hospitals that were
threatening they were saying don't
bother sending us your patients
wow wow in the end
silver lake reported two confirmed
coveted deaths at the facility
six out of facility and 37 presumed
covet deaths
the numbers are not the lowest in the
state but far
from the highest so you following your
gut do you think that made a difference
knowing my population i think i would i
we would have we would have had a lot
more loss of life
there has to be a better regard for the
elderly population and the
population of residents in nursing homes
that are sick they're vulnerable and i
think
they should have been given a much
higher priority
in may of 2020 governor cuomo amended
his nursing home order
now hospitalized residents must test
negative before being readmitted to a
nursing home
but was the damage already done did the
march
25 directive put these facilities in an
unreasonable position
they were petrified but they were more
petrified of the department of health
new york's attorney general found
insufficient ppe
and testing at nursing homes put
residents at
increased risk of harm fifteen thousand
people
died in nursing homes and long-term care
facilities
governor cuomo repeatedly insists his
order
was not the driving cause do you think
that's fair do you believe that
so not entirely i really feel
that when the hospitals kept on pushing
us to take these residents i think that
was a very big mistake
our many thanks to michael krause for
speaking on camera
about this aisha hosni did that
interview she joins us live now aisha
thank you
we learned a lot there what did cuomo
know about the warnings
sandra that's a great question obviously
you heard
michael krause in that piece basically
say look there were state officials in
these
uh coveted conference calls when i spoke
up so we have to assume that there were
state officials that heard
his warnings his uh ringing the alarm
we did reach out to the governor's
office to find out if he was aware of
this we haven't heard back yet
the department of health though did
respond to our request for common here's
what they say they say
that march 25th guidance they're calling
it
was not a directive to accept covid19
patients appoint the attorney general's
office
finds the nursing homes understood so
that's what they're saying and
essentially
what they're saying is that the ag found
that it was
reasonable for nursing homes to have
understood don't take these patients if
you're not adequately prepared now that
last part adequately prepared
that was part of the federal guidance
coming down from the cdc
it was not included in the state's order
that march 25th order so obviously some
people out there would say
nursing homes uh perhaps did not take it
that way
yeah and yet cuomo insists that he
followed cdc guidance in disorder so
the big picture question here aisha is
did cuomo's order lead to an increase
in nursing home deaths from covid where
do we stand on that question
yeah i'm glad you asked that because i
feel like that question has really
gotten
lost as we've sort of gone on this path
that's
you know winding in all sorts of
directions as all these controversies
kind of arise around the governor
the answer is we don't know and we don't
know that anyone is really looking into
that
really important and serious question we
know that the department of justice
began to look into it
back in august they were actually just
looking into whether they should launch
an investigation into that question or
not
we're not aware that they ever did we
know that yesterday though
several lawmakers here in new york
including congresswoman
elise stefanik she did call out for the
doj
to go ahead and now launch an
investigation
into that question she wants the doj to
find out if
this order violates the civil rights of
those residents that were living
in these group homes great reporting
aisha
yeah thank you for bringing that to us
you bet